[Musique]
il est le président du conseil de
l'union européenne pour six mois et
c'est en cette qualité qu emmanuel
macron s'exprime devant les 705 députés
du parlement européen
c'est un marchepied c'est un marche pied
pour un discours électoral resterait
dans l'histoire monsieur le président de
la république le président de l'inaction
climatique
parce qu'au fond vous êtes un climato
arrangeant votre bilan européen n'est
qu'arrogant ce impuissance et manigances
sur le fond vous êtes le champion des
compromissions et des doubles discours
mais sur la fin vous n'avez cessé d'être
le président du mépris vous et vos
alliés avaient fait de l'europe
l'arrière-cour de washington la proie de
pékin le paillasson d'erdogan et l'hôtel
de l'afrique une fois de plus je vous le
rappelle ce n'est pas un débat national
nous discutons des priorités françaises
pour l'union et nous nous devons de
respecter cette institution alors que la
france a besoin de rayonner de nouveau
pour exprimer sa puissance vous avez
éteint sa lumière pour la france mais
aussi pour l'europe il est vital que
votre mandat reste unique vous avez fait
au fond un
texte assez franco français de tous les
reproches vous avez quand même je dois
le salut est
très méthodiquement dit n'importe quoi
surtout les textes européens que nous
pouvions ceni macro ont fait du
maquereau voilà à partir du moment où
vous êtes en désaccord avec lui il
insulte il fait preuve de mépris fait
preuve de cynisme sans jamais vous le
leur ai noté me répondre sur le fond
était assez convenue je trouve c'est à
dire que on retrouve un peu le côté en
même temps du duo acronis mme il a été
parfaitement conforme à ce que nous
attendions de lui ce fut le discours de
l'acharnement thérapeutique
pour une union qui ne fonctionne plus
depuis longtemps
un nouveau coup de pouce pour
l'hôtellerie la restauration et
l'événementiel c'est ce qu'a annoncé le
premier ministre jean castex est une
aide exceptionnelle dit il pendant deux
mois qui concerne les entreprises de
moins de 250 salariés nous allons signer
avec le gouverneur de la banque de
france avec la fédération bancaire
française un accord sur la possibilité
de décaler le remboursement de son prêt
garanti par l'état et d'étaler le
remboursement il était fixé à 6 ans on
pourrait d'étaler jusqu'à disons je me
suis clairement posé la question de ma
participation à cette émission ce soir
en raison de l'ouverture d'une enquête
par la justice à la suite d'une plainte
déposée contre monsieur bourdin pour
tentative d'agression sexuelle je
réprouve
l'instrumentalisation immédiate
politique est là comme bien sûr la com
qui arrive tout de suite je viens de
vous en parler là comme des politiques
et bien là on a eu droit évidemment
aussi à un exercice de communication
j'ai pris la décision de me retirer de
la course présidentielle
moi j'ai foi en la justice
pas vraiment les journalistes j'ai
décidé de ne pas m'exprimer à ce sujet
mais je conteste les faits rapportés par
la presse et je laisse la justice faire
son travail gaspard ulliel avait 37 ans
sa mort a été confirmée cet après midi
par son agent je vous rappelle que les
faits sont prescrits
ce qui n'empêche pas une enquête ouverte
et que la justice va la justice faire
son travail et ne me ramenez pas
uniquement à être la femme de jean
jacques bourdin c'est au croisement de
ces deux pistes près de ce poteau orange
qu'il fait une chute à ski après une
collision avec un autre skieur celui ci
est indemne gaspard ulliel qui ne
portait pas de casque est lui victime
d'un traumatisme crânien